on s'arrête maintenant sur cette
interview exclusive pour france 2 sel je
vous le disais d'un des chefs d'état les
plus contestées les plus secrets aussi
le président syrien bachar el assad
il a reçu l'une de nos équipes il
s'explique sur la crise libanaise sur
l'irak justement mais aussi sur ses
relations devenues très froide avec
jacques chirac
un entretien signé thierry thuillier et
edward perrin le palais présidentiel est
là où au bout de cette route
bachar al assad il reçoit beaucoup mais
se montre peu les émissaires occidentaux
ont repris le chemin de damas pour le
consulter c'est la fin de deux ans
d'isolement pour ce chef d'état dont les
services ont été montrées du doigt dans
l'enquêté sur l'assassinât de l'ancien
premier ministre libanais rafic hariri
yann dazé la mirabelle isoler la syrie
ne peut avoir de résultats positifs aux
manières et isoler la syrie aux ciseaux
lui même les problèmes de la région
prendrait lui même pourquoi
pour autant avec un pays comme la france
les choses ne vont pas bien les
relations sont au plus bas depuis
combien de temps n'avez vous pas parlé à
jacques chirac
depuis 2004 je crois c'est long c'est
très long ça correspond à la durée de la
rupture des relations politiques franco
syrien je peux dire que ce n'est pas une
bonne chose pour les relations entre nos
deux pays
mais de toute évidence celle qui en a
pâti c'est la france fraikin parce que
la france dirigeait la politique
européenne dans la région et maintenant
on n'entend plus parler de la politique
étrangère de la france au moins au
moyen-orient sur sa responsabilité et
celle des services syriens dans
l'assassinât de rafic hariri
il répond personne ne peut accuser sans
preuve qu'il soit le président chirac ou
toute autre personne celui qui veut
accuser la syrie doit donner des preuves
on ne peut pas bâtir des relations entre
deux pays sur des émotions personnelles
elles doivent être bâtis sur des
réalités des intérêts communs cette
accusation est totalement inadmissible
qu'est ce que vous diriez à jacques
chirac si vous
vous aviez la possibilité de lui parler
ou de le rencontrer avant la fin de son
mandat je le dirai où est le problème
entre la france et la syrie
il y a le liban et sa crise enfin damas
propose pour sortir de l'impasse des
élections anticipées et un gouvernement
d'union nationale
et si un tribunal international est créé
dans la sphère hariri bachar al assad ne
livrera aucun syrien j'ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises que toute personne
impliquée dans cette affaire est
considéré comme un traître devant la loi
syrienne aux canons à eau
elle sera jugée par un tribunal syrien
et condamné bien plus sévèrement
il ne le ferait tout autre tribunal nous
ne céderons pas notre souveraineté
ça fait maintenant quatre ans que la
guerre a commencé en irak
quel bilan tirez-vous non pas seulement
de l'action américaine en irak mais dans
l'ensemble de la région
il n'est pas dans notre intérêt d'avoir
le chaos dans un pays voisin leur nid de
l'y maintenir parce que nous allons
directement payer la facture
tôt ou tard elle mène des années plus
tard nous finiront par payer d'une façon
ou d'une autre la page est le principal
allié de la syrie dans la région c'est
l'iran d'ahmadinejad qui menacent de
rayer israël de la carte
bachar al assad entreprend pourtant de
le défendre
si nous devons considérer cette
déclaration pourquoi ne pas considérer
l'autre celle où il dit que l'iran ne
constitue aucune menace pour les autres
pourquoi choisir une déclaration et pas
l'autre l'important c'est la politique
appliquée d'un autre côté des
personnalités israéliennes religieuses
et politiques ont fait des déclarations
similaires
un peu lentes à utiliser la bombe contre
les palestiniens et les arabes ou à les
éliminer vont pas dissocier les
provocations et les réactions qu'elle
suscite
machar al assad nous dira aussi son
souhait de refonder la relation avec la
france avec le futur président de la
république
confessant au passage ne pas connaître
les principaux candidats